نبدا نشرتنا من اخر التطورات الاحتجاجات
في ايران حيث نشرت السلطات المزيده من
قواتها في مدينه بركان الكرديه في محافظه
اذربيجان الغربيه وهي منطقه شهدت مظاهرات
حاشده خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
بالتزامن مع احتجاجات المدن الكرديه
الاخرى غربيه ايران
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا واعلن صدف فاطمه زوجه الصحفيه
الرياضيه الايراني مهدي امير بور عن
اعتقاله زوجها بسبب تضامنه مع الاحتجاجات
ونقله الى سجن ايفين في طهران وذلك بحسب
ما نشره موقع ايران انترناشونال وبحسب صدف
فاطمه فقد هجم عناصر الامن منزلهم في
الساعه الثانيه من بعد منتصف الليل واعتقل
زوجها ويذكر انه في الشهرين الماضيين تم
اعتقاله عدد من الصحفيين الرياضيين من
بينهم نيلوفر حميدي واليه جعفري واحسان
بربرناش وسعيده فتحي
قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني حسين سلامه
جدده هجومه على المحتجين ووصف الاحتجاجات
بانها مدبره ووصل سلام انتقاداته
للاحتجاجات وقال انها حرب كبيره ضد النظام
في ايران تشنها دول غربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اه
[موسيقى]
هذا ويواصل النظام في ايران الداخليه
بوسائله المتعدده في وقت تحدث فيه تقرير
استخباراتيه غربيه عن تهديد السلطات
للمعارضين في الخارج
واشتكى صحافيون ايرانيون في بريطانيا من
تهديدات وصفوها بالخطيره قالوا انها من
طرف السلطات الايرانيه كما كشفت المخابرات
الكنديه عن تقارير لديها قالت انها حملت
تهديدات ايرانيه بالقتل ضد معارضين
والصحفيين ايرانيين داخل كندا واوضح
المتحدث باسم المخابرات الكنديه ريك بلسم
لهيئه الاذاعه الكنديه ان التهديدات تشمل
المراقبه والترهيب وتستهدف اسكات من
ينتقدون النظام كما تقود امن وسيادتك كندا
على حد تعبير وذلك مع السعر مع الصحفيين
والمعارضين من تغطيه الاحتجاجات الواسعه
في مختلف المدن الايرانيه والتي ادت الى
مقتل مئات الايرانيين باي عناصر الامن حسب
مراكز حقوقيه
وقد اندلعت الاحتجاجات في سبتمبر الماضي
اذا مقتل الشاب مهسا اميني بعد تعرضها
للتعذيب على يد شرطه الاخلاق